>> GOOD MORNING, HONEY.
I'M SORRY.
I DIDN'T MAKE YOU BREAKFAST.
BUT OUR SON DID.
>> HAPPY MOTHER'S DAY, MOMMY.
>> OH, HONEY!
THIS IS SO GREAT!
ARE YOU THE SWEETEST.
THANK YOU, SWEETHEART.
>> I HELPED A LITTLE BIT ON THE
EGGS, BUT HE DID THE TOAST ALL
BY HIMSELF.
>> WELL, MMM.
THIS IS THE BEST TOAST I HAVE
EVER HAD.
>> REALLY?
YES!
>> REALLY.
I AM SO LUCKY TO BE YOUR MOMMY.
THE DAY YOU WERE BORN WAS THE
BEST DAY OF MY LIFE.
>> WHAT WAS IT LIKE?
>> THE DAY YOU WERE BORN?
IT WAS AMAZING.
>> ONLY A FEW MORE CENTIMETERS
AND YOU'LL BE READY.
>> HOW MUCH BIGGER CAN THE HOLE
GET?
>> JUST BREATHE.
>> IT HURTS!
>> WERE YOU SCARED, MOMMY?
>> OH, NO.
I WAS EXCITED.
I HAD A BIG SMILE ON MY FACE THE
WHOLE TIME.
DIDN'T I?
>> OH, YEAH.
>> WE HAVE TO PERFORM AN
EPISIOTOMY.
>> NO, DON'T!
>> WHY DOES IT LOOK LIKE THAT.
>> WERE YOU SCARED?
>> DADDIES DON'T GET SCARED.
>> I'M NOT READY!
>> THE NICE DOCTOR CAME IN AND
TOLD US IT WAS TIME.
>> WHERE HAVE YOU BEEN?
>> SHE TOLD ME TO GIVE ONE
LITTLE PUSH.
>> HE'S CROWNING.
ONE MORE PUSH!
>> AM I POOPING?
AM I POOPING?
>> NO, BABY, NO.
>> WITH ONE LITTLE PUSH, YOU
WERE BORN.
YOU WERE THE MOST BEAUTIFUL BABY
IN THE WHOLE WORLD.
>> WHY DOES HE LOOK LIKE THAT.
WHY IS HE YELLOW?
IS THAT NORMAL?
>> WHY IS HE SO UGLY?
>> THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
BEST DAY OF MY LIFE.
YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE?
EVERY DAY SINCE THEN HAS BEEN
BETTER THAN THE DAY BEFORE.
>> WHERE ARE IS MY HOCKEY STUFF?
>> IN THE HALL CLOSET.
I MIGHT GET A DRINK AFTER.
>> I LOVE YOU, MOMMY.
>> OH, I LOVE YOU TOO, HONEY.
>> MOMMY?
>> YEAH?
>> I HAD AN ACCIDENT LAST NIGHT.
>> I'M SURE DADDY CLEANED IT UP.
>> NO, I WANTED YOU TO CLEAN IT.